sont venus procès Bam Bam Bam 18 empire
bam prison 3 mois où j'avais jamais
connu la prison qu'est-ce que tu veux je
suis rentré j'étais un agneau je suis
sorti j'étais à Lyon
j'étais à Tunis on était tous à Tunis
mon père avait une boucherie mon
grand-père avec une boucherie et on
était à la Goulette les Tunisiens alors
la Goulette ça veut dire c'est comme si
tu habitais en France mais en réalité tu
habitais à Cannes tu as compris non pas
à Paris la boulette à Tunis c'est ça on
habitait au bord de la mer la porte
était toujours ouverte l'autre voisin
demandait du miel ou demander de l'huile
on vivait en famille c'est à dire on
vivait musulmans chrétiens français
portugais il y avait pas de race la race
n'existait pas j'étais hyper gâté on
était trois enfants ça veut dire les
autres n'étaient pas né les autres sont
nés à Paris on était moi ma grande sœur
qui a un an de plus et mon petit frère
qui a un an de moi et mon père parce que
lui c'était déjà un homme à l'âge de 10
ans c'est à l'époque tu étais déjà un
homme très jeune parce qu'il fallait
travailler très jeune
j'avais pas le droit d'aller à l'école
et moi j'étais gâté c'est à dire que
j'avais tout j'avais mon bateau
plastique j'avais mon scooter où j'avais
8 ans j'avais un scooter avec un mec
devant moi qui conduisait j'avais tout
ce que je voulais et un jour mon père il
est parti à Paris ouais il est parti à
Paris il est revenu 6 mois après à Tunis
je savais pas pourquoi comment donc
j'avais les boules il revient tac tac
tac d'un seul coup on fait nos affaires
et on s'en va 504 tac tac on prend de
ferry on arrive à Marseille Paris on
sait pas où on va attaque premier soir
on dort dans la voiture ok deuxième soir
on a un hôtel tout pourri à Belleville
une semaine impasse de semaine passent
trois semaines elle passe chaque mon
père il s'en va il s'en va à Tunis d'un
seul coup nous moi aimer on était trois
enfants tac tac on arrive on a pas
d'hôtel mais moi je comprends pas
pourquoi on a pas d'hôtel je comprends
pas pourquoi on a pas de maison je
comprends pas pourquoi on a pas d'hôtel
on dort on dort dans un couloir dans un
porche mais moi c'était une colonie pour
moi c'était marrant pour moi de dormir
je je suis sorti du port j'allais voir
les gens dans la rue à Belleville façon
à Belleville rester jusqu'à 3h du matin
par terre les pieds dans l'eau et un
jour ma mère on se lève le matin il y a
pas de croissant et là j'ai rien dit
j'ai c'est ma maman j'ai dit maman je
veux un pain au chocolat après et moi
j'insiste tu vois j'en suis âgé elle me
dit après je te promets que je vais te
l'acheter je te promets que je vais te
l'acheter alors à la fin je sais pas
comment faire va nous acheter une
baguette enfin du pain quoi je sais même
pas si la baguette existé mais je pense
que le pain était gros et nous donne un
morceau de poche chacun mais rien
d'autre regarde comment ça doit être
vexant en face de toi il y a ta maman
elle se démerde elle décompte pour
donner à manger par n'importe quel moyen
et toi tu lui dis maman je ne veux pas
ça je veux un pain au chocolat mais toi
tu sais pas qu'elle a pas les moyens de
te l'acheter impossible tu vivais dans
un rêve tu vivais à la mer au soleil tu
avais tout ce que tu veux du jour au
lendemain on te dit tu as plus rien et
un jour et je vois ma mère demander un
front à mon grand-père je suis maman
je comprends pas pourquoi tu vas pas
avoir papa et tu donnes de l'argent
parce que là j'avais compris qu'on était
en manque d'argent et elle m'a dit mon
fils
j'aime tellement ton père que je préfère
rester fier travailler et ne rien
réclamer personne va m'acheter ni ton
père ni personne et mes enfants se sont
mes enfants si tu as envie d'aller voir
ton père va le boire mais pour toi pas
pour moi mais regarde comment ma mère me
parle et j'ai 10 ans j'ai 10 ans mais
c'est-à-dire regarde un môme de 10 ans
elle te parle comme un homme de 40 ans
ça veut dire que déjà ma mère comptait
sur moi s'il répondait de l'homme de la
famille pour elle c'était plus mon père
c'était moi l'homme de la famille et là
je lui ai dit je lui ai dit je lui ai
dit maman tu manqueras plus jamais
d'argent et puis là quand tu es
responsable d'une famille par n'importe
quel moyen faut leur ramener à manger
c'est où on crevette faim ou on dormait
par terre où j'allais faire ce que
j'avais à faire pour ma famille j'aurais
aimé à l'équiper avec mes copains
j'aurais aimé aller à l'école rigoler
17h rentrer à la maison pour aller voir
la télé décoder en bas avec mes amis moi
j'ai pas eu tout ça moi j'étais privé
d'enfance moi ma vie elle a été faite de
travail moi j'ai fait les marchés à 4
heures du matin j'avais 14 ans il
faisait moins 5 degrés j'étais dans le
gel en train de mélanger de nettoyer les
tomates à 15 ans par exemple avant les
banques étaient faciles pour nous avant
la pièce d'identité c'était pas ça avant
tu fabriquais ta piloté à l'imprimerie
ça veut dire au kiosque réellement si
c'est du papier donc c'est vrai que
c'était facile pour nous avant tu
mettais un chèque il donnait les espèces
avant tu mettais 300 millions dans un
sac tu as la banque qui te les prenait
tout était facile aujourd'hui tu
présentes à une banque bonjour tata je
m'appelle Sébastien un peu plus mentir
tu donnes ton vrai nom bonjour je
m'appelle monsieur moulu ben sur
Internet waouh ah non on peut pas vous
garder on peut pas vous prendre à la
banque monsieur non c'est pas possible
qu'avant ce truc là n'existait pas avant
que tu avais le droit de mentir
aujourd'hui tu ne peux plus mentir vous
savez j'ai monté une boîte coté en
bourse j'avais 18 ans ça s'appelait je
vous le dis aujourd'hui de télécom City
j'avais 18 ans j'étais pas marié j'avais
pas d'enfants mais je me suis dit [ __ ]
mes enfants vont être heureux avec cette
boîte puis un jour rebelote je me fais
attraper par la police mais j'avais une
vraie boîte
et la police elle m'a dit seulement vous
avez oublié un CMR je sais quoi c'est
mer c'est le certificat de passer les
douanes avec les marchandises moi j'ai
dit excusez-moi je vous promets que je
savais pas et ben non il n'y a pas vous
savez pas au procès 3 ans ils m'ont fait
devenir qui je suis ils m'ont fait
devenir parce que je suis un garçon qui
me réveille je suis un garçon qui va
avoir les choses donc c'est pas moi qui
a dit pourtant je veux vous voler c'est
pas moi qui a dit je veux me venger
c'est eux qui m'ont dit c'est comme ça
et c'est pas autrement ça veut dire
qu'il n'y a pas de dialogue c'est à dire
tu es simple tu es un garçon simple tu
es un garçon de la rue et ben tu es une
merde ils sont venus procès
bam prison 3 mois où j'avais jamais
connu la prison qu'est-ce que tu veux je
suis rentré j'étais un agneau je suis
sorti j'étais à Lyon on est dans un
système
professionnel que si tu es pas malin et
si tu as pas compris tout ça tu peux pas
aller leur leur monde et moi je suis un
garçon qui a été dans leur monde mais
comme je n'ai pas été accepté dans leur
monde j'ai fait à ma manière voilà je me
suis servi tout seul les bêtises que
j'ai fait il faut avoir de l'estomac et
il faut avoir un savoir-faire quand même
attention c'est pas un vol de TVA c'est
vraiment des structurations c'est dans
le monde entier c'est des banques c'est
quand même une grosse structuration qui
est qui comme si qui était au CAC 40
quand tu montes un truc comme ça bien
sûr que c'est pas bien sûr que c'est du
vol de te vas c'est mais c'est même
c'est même certain c'est du vol parce
qu'en réalité même si c'est du manque à
gagner ça appartient à tout le monde
mais attends payez-moi au moins je vous
crée une structure je vous crée un
chiffre d'affaires ok payez-moi et je
continue à vous le créer bien sûr le
problème c'est que les plus grandes
écoles quand tu vois les plus grandes
écoles de la caisse d'épaule des
conciliation qui sont là-bas qu'ils ont
fait des études de rêve j'adore leur
faire du mal j'adore les piquer parce
que je leur fais montrer que même moi si
j'ai pas été à l'école
ils ont du souci à se faire et ils se
remettent en question et ils se
remettent en question voilà je les aide
en vérité ça veut dire que j'ai fait une
conférence pour des gens de des vrais
gens des eux ils voulaient savoir
c'était quoi le système négatif dans le
système positif d'accord j'ai fait HEC
je sais pas si tu sais j'ai fait quand
même HEC
jamais de ma vie j'aurais pu croire que
j'aurais fait moi un courage je sais
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que les gens les gens intelligents ne
sont pas malins et ça c'est réel ne sont
pas mal hein mais c'est quand même la
chose la plus importante si dans dans
ton carnet d'adresses enfin dans ton
cahier d'école tu n'es pas mal hein ça
sert à rien d'être intelligent et c'est
pour ça que l'école de la rue est plus
important que l'intelligence pourquoi
parce que si tu as les deux tu deviens
le meilleur mec au monde parce que
l'école de la rue t'apprend des choses
on te baise on essaye de t'arnaquer on
essaie de te voler tabou on essaie de
faire du mal c'est tout le l'école de la
rue et l'école la vraie école c'est tout
le bien on t'apprend voilà c'est 2 x 4 =
chi facile d'apprendre puis tu
enregistre et puis tu fais mais l'école
de la rue tu peux pas enregistrer c'est
de l'émotion moi je regrette un truc je
sais pas lire et écrire mais qu'est-ce
que j'aurais aimé savoir lire écrire
voilà et ça tu vois pour moi c'est la
base la base pour moi le reste c'est la
rue tu regardes moi je suis sortie de
prison tu sais sur TPMP j'ai dit une
connerie j'ai dit que j'avais 310
millions d'euros mais c'était pour
rigoler j'ai pas compris mais il y a une
chose c'est je garde bien ma vie très
bien ma vie ça veut dire de la prison je
suis sorti je gagne très bien ma vie je
veux pas dire qu'est-ce que je gagne
qu'est-ce que je gagne pas n'oubliez pas
que je suis surveillé mais qu'est-ce que
j'ai envie de le dire en vérité pourquoi
j'ai envie de le dire c'est parce que je
veux te faire montrer aux gens même si
vous savez pas lire ni écrire même si
vous manque des dents ils vous manque
des cheveux il vous manque un bras il y
a pas plus facile c'est à l'intérieur
que ça se passe c'est pas l'extérieur il
y a des têtes d'affiches il y a des gens
qui sont nés riches mais très riches qui
eux ils ont pas de problème il va
s'avancer la vie est faite leurs
petits-enfants des générations et des
générations moi mon problème à nous
c'est que on était étrangers on est
venus avec un bagage on est venu avec
rien du tout qu'une valise en carton GP
ma tête d'accord j'ai su faire tout seul
comme ça je dois rien à personne j'ai
souffert on m'a pris l'argent qu'est-ce
que je peux rembourser je vais
rembourser d'accord parce que je peux
pas aller voler pour rembourser parce
que si l'état il me demande de
rembourser tout de suite donc il demande
d'aller voler en vérité d'aller faire un
autre braquage d'accord et ben je ferai
ce que je peux faire il suffit que là
j'ai fait une belle affaire le téléphone
du sol
tu comprends je me frime je frime je
ferai plus de secondes après on envoie
un texto allô la banque t'a bloqué la
journée elle est noire quand c'est noir
c'est noir 24 heures quand tu es
heureuse tu es heureux deux minutes un
jour on m'a jeté d'un restaurant on m'a
dans une boîte quoi pas une boîte à un
pied un restaurant un restaurant un
festif et ben on m'a pas jeté mais
j'étais le garçon un peu exubérant pour
eux tu vois c'était pas j'étais un peu
le garçon avec jubérant et ben par mon
orgueil et tout ça j'ai acheté le
restaurant j'ai acheté pour dire
maintenant c'est moi qui vous renvoie
c'est plus vous qui me renvoyez plus me
l'enlever celui-là c'est fini j'ai donné
à une association qui est votre cœur
écoutez votre tête écouter Dieu on s'en
foutez des conseilleurs ne sont pas les
payeurs et les payeurs ne sont pas des
conseilleurs donc aller gagner votre vie
je vous aime je vous embrasse